local family is still looking for their
missing 16 year old son chase williamson
was last seen friday in the northwest
valley near hualapai and 2 15. his
mother says chase left for work at a
pizza restaurant and when she went to
pick him up he was already gone on
saturday chase's bike was found in a
dumpster behind an albertson's about
five miles away
no we haven't retrieved the bike yet
we're going to pick that up today
we were mainly focused on getting out
the report to the police putting this
all over social media and trying to talk
to any of his friends online that we
could
and finding out if anybody had seen him
the williamson family says chase's phone
has been off since he left work that day
chase williamson is 510 about 155 pounds
short brown hair blue eyes and braces
you can see him on your screen right
there williamson was last seen wearing
blue jeans and a pink mr jim's shirt and
also may have been wearing a black visor
at the time if you have any information
please call police